There are new reports that Donald Trump is
regularly not coming into work until noon
and that he is rage watching five to seven
Houser's of television every morning.
And my feelings about this are sort of mixed.
Then I'll tell you, why do we want Trump doing
more work in the sense that when Trump works,
he's mostly doing bad things, he's incompetent,
he's hurting people, he's hurting the country
the more that he works.
We'll discuss that in a moment.
The report is that Katie Rogers and Annie
CARNEY say at The New York Times that during
coronavirus, Trump has this routine that he's
sort of gotten into, that he's often showing
up to the Oval Office around noon or later.
He's typically in a terrible mood from all
of the TV.
He's been watching all morning.
It starts as early as 5:00 a.m. with Fox News.
He watches CNN.
He's watching MSNBC.
We know this is true because he often tweets
about CNN or about Morning Joe on MSNBC.
At exactly those times.
And it seems to fire him up even more.
And he's showing up to work very, very upset.
Trump will also, as he's watching TV for five
to seven hours every morning, he'll get on
the phone with advisers and complain to them
about how he's not being portrayed as a great
savior when it comes to Corona virus.
And what we have also learned from this article
in The New York Times excellent article is
that the nightly press briefings that Trump
has been doing most evenings are basically
the only thing he has to look forward to.
And that actually explains a lot and sheds
a ton of light onto the question of we've
been wondering why is he doing these press
briefings almost constantly.
Every single one sees him digging himself
into a deeper and deeper hole, culminating
Thursday with wondering aloud about injecting
bleach and isopropyl alcohol.
He's not helping himself.
He's arguably hurting himself.
And indeed, it seems as though the reason
he's doing it is because it's all that he
has going on.
And indeed, when you look at Donald Trump's
calendar, it matches up with this reporting.
Yesterday, for example, Donald Trump's first
scheduled thing was 2 p.m. and it was just
a conference call last Friday.
Similarly, Trump had nothing on his calendar
before noon when he signed the bill.
And then you have his defenders, like, for
example, the new press secretary, Kaley McKenney.
She pops up and she defends Trump and says
it's all fake news and they always go too
far in the defenses.
Like if she put out there a sort of realistic
defense of Trump's work ethic and schedule,
it might be believable.
But she goes way too far here.
She says Trump is working so much that he
sometimes forgets to eat.
Mark Meadows was asked about what his concern
is day to day as he looks at the president's
schedule.
And he made the point that the president is
so busy and so hard at work.
I mean, his concern is making sure he gets
a bite to eat here and there.
So, you know, you've got to put that into
context.
First of all, of course, we are concerned
for America's workers.
So obviously, we know that's not true.
Obviously, Donald Trump is not forgetting
to eat.
He is likely technically obese.
If we evaluate what we believe his actual
weight is, there's no indication, whatever,
that he's missing meals unless he is actually
on uppers, as some people suspect.
And uppers tend to take away your appetite.
But usually you're making up for it by bingeing
later in the day, once you've come down from
the uppers.
So it just it's not it's too much.
It's not believable.
The report that Trump isn't coming until noon
and barely working seems to be well sourced
to then come back and say Trump works harder
than anyone and is sometimes forgetting to
eat.
It's too much and it's not believable.
And that gets us to the practical question
do we want Trump working?
This was a question before the Corona virus
fiasco, before the Corona virus pandemic,
where we would talk about Trump's golf trips.
Trump to date has golf.
Two hundred and sixty four days during his
presidency.
And that is a sign of an incredibly lazy person
with a poor work ethic.
But at the same time, do we want Trump working
when he does terrible things when he actually
works?
We talked about testing earlier today.
Trump should have built a proper testing apparatus
for Corona virus.
He should have built a proper contact tracing
apparatus for Corona virus.
But would he have gotten it done if he came
into work at 10 a.m. instead of noon?
Or would he simply have done other things
that would have been bad?
I don't know.
What I can tell you is I've never watched
seven hours of TV in a day in my life.
Maybe if I was like home sick, I watched five
hours, maybe like a couple times in my life.
I can't remember this guy.
Is the president and he has time for five
to seven hours of television a day.
He often tweets dozens of times a day.
He's sometimes gotten close to 100 hundred
tweets and retweets in a single day.
I just run a little independent show with
a few employees and I don't nearly have the
time for this.
This guy's the president.
So it's bizarre.
But I want to hear your reaction.
Do we really want Trump working more, given
that the more he does, the more bad things
he's doing?
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter
at
David Pakman.